[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Katja streso für
den Sport guten Abend schauen wir auf
die Themen von heute
selensky beim g7-gipfel der ukrainische
Präsident wird in Hiroshima für die
Kampfjet Koalition Deutschland will sich
nicht beteiligen
Hochwasser und Erdrutsche im Norden
Italiens kämpfen die Menschen weiter
gegen die Folgen der Überflutung neue
regenwetterwartet
Freud und Leid im Fußball Hertha BSC
steht als erster
bundesliga-absteigerfest Darmstadt
feiert nach sechs Jahren den
Wiederaufstieg
[Musik]
der Besuch des ukrainischen Präsidenten
auf den g7-gipfel in Japan hat das
Programm durcheinandergewirbelt schon
einen Tag vor gipfelende
veröffentlichten die Regierungschefs der
sieben großen demokratischen
Industrienationen ihre
Abschlusserklärung darin versuchen sie
unter anderem einen Balanceakt mit China
sie üben deutliche Kritik an Peking
zeigen sich aber zugleich offen für
Zusammenarbeit der Ukraine sichern Sie
unerschütterliche Unterstützung zu davon
gilt es allerdings noch die anderen
gipfelgäste zu überzeugen aus Hiroshima
Andreas Kühnast
für die japanischen Sicherheitsbeamten
ist heute Marathontag neben insgesamt 16
Regierungschefs muss durch Hiroshima
gejoggt werden vor allem Schwellenländer
wie Vietnam folgen der Einladung zu den
G7 aber nicht deren Argumenten
Indonesiens Präsident VODO hat Russland
nicht verurteilt Brasiliens Präsident
Lula gibt dem Westen eine Mitschuld und
Indiens premiermodi lässt Unmengen
russisches Öl kaufen und weiterverkaufen
obwohl er sonst als Verteidiger des
internationalen Rechts auftritt und
genau das ist der Punkt wo wir in den
überzeugen können das ist bei Russlands
Aggressionen gegen die Ukraine um mehr
geht als nur eine Frage zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine sondern es geht
darum was sind die Regeln in dieser Welt
ein Handschlag na gut Kanzler Scholz hat
sich innerhalb der G7 zum Anwalt von
Schwellenländern wie Brasilien gemacht
und wie kein anderer auch westliche
Doppelstandards kritisiert eine Wende in
der Unterstützung der Ukraine leitet
US-Präsident beiden ein und zeigt sich
nun doch bereit erst kampfjetpiloten
auszubilden und später F16 Jets liefern
zu lassen Präsident selensky war am
Nachmittag nach Japan gekommen
und dankt im ZDF allen Ländern die
Flugzeuge beisteuern wollen
die Entscheidung heißt nicht dass wir
diese Verteidigungsmaßnahmen morgen
haben werden wir müssen uns vorbereiten
aber egal es ist ein großartiges
Ergebnis vielen Dank an alle Länder
unsere Partner
wir treffen uns jetzt aber oft sagt
Kanzler Scholz der zur Kampfjet
Koalition nichts beitragen kann und auch
nicht will neben den USA den vor allem
Frankreich und Großbritannien voran
Gruppenbild mit Gästen aber ohne
silensky noch ist nicht sicher ob sich
die Welt nach dem Gipfel anders
aufstellt als davor
Hiroshima bekommt die Ukraine
tatsächlich Kampfjets geliefert
nein sie bekommt jetzt nicht gleich
Kampfjets geliefert es werden jetzt erst
mal Kampfjet Piloten ausgebildet das
dauert vier Monate aber das wirklich
bedeutsame ist dass eben jetzt Amerika
sein Widerstand aufgegeben hat und jetzt
generell bereit ist Kampfjets zu liefern
die Amerikaner haben gesagt wir machen
das von der gesamten militärlage in der
Ukraine abhängig ob wir sie liefern oder
nicht und das heißt man baut jetzt Druck
auf Russland auf und wenn man will sagen
Moskau wenn ihr weiter in der Ukraine
eskaliert werden wir eben Kampfjets
liefern damit die Ukraine sich noch
besser und noch effizienter verteidigen
kann ob diese Strategie aufgeht ob sich
Russland einschüchtern lässt oder ob das
eine weitere Eskalation ist das kann
Moment keiner sagen
Stichwort Druck auf Russland was ist
damit China wird Peking den Druck auf
Russland ausüben sowie dass die G7
fordern
auch das kann man schwer sagen aber eins
ist auch klar geworden hier in diesem
Tag die G7 hat sich doch sehr eindeutig
positioniert und hat gesagt auch wenn
China wirtschaftlich sehr mächtig ist
wir sind bereit uns mitschiener
anzulegen und das heißt wir sind auch
bereit notfalls China mit Sanktionen
abzustrafen oder wirtschaftliche
Konsequenzen einzugehen das
entscheidende was ihr deutlich geworden
ist ist dass der Ukraine Krieg zwischen
dem Westen und China liegt die Ukraine
der die china muss Russland Druck
ausüben das ist quasi die Aufgabe die
jetzt die sieben China gestellt hat und
wenn es das nicht tut wird es ein
weiteren Konflikt geben und das hat man
doch mal deutlich gemacht danke schön
für diese Information und live aus
Hiroshima ultra war das
wie umgehen mit China dazu äußert sich
auch
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
exklusiv bei uns wenn Sie das nachlesen
möchten dann schauen Sie in die ZDF
heute App
seit Monaten wird erbittert um die
ukrainische Stadt bachmut gekämpft mit
wohlerheblichen Verlusten auf beiden
Seiten heute verkündete der Chef der
russischen Söldnertruppe Wagner prigoshi
die komplette Einnahme der Stadt in
einer Videobotschaft behauptet er man
habe bachmut von Haus zu Haus
vollständig eingenommen seine Truppe
werde die Stadt im Osten der Ukraine
jetzt sichern in fünf Tagen soll bachmut
ans russische Militär übergeben werden
fragen wir unseren Reporter in der
Ukraine Tim Krüger stimmt das hat die
Ukraine den Kampf umbachmut verloren
das ist noch nicht ganz sicher bislang
ist es ja nur der seltener Chef prigoshi
in der sagt das bachmut vollständig
eingenommen ist er hat auch gesagt dass
er die Stadt jetzt erstmal an die
reguläre russische Armee übergeben will
und dass er sich dann dass er sich dann
ausmachen Mut zurückziehen will von
offizieller russischer Seite haben wir
noch keine Bestätigung dafür bekommen
und die ukrainische Seite dementiert das
ganze sie sagt es wird nach wie vor
heftig im Bach Mut gekämpft auch wenn
die Lage kritisch sei wenn es aber
stimmt was bringt euch in der heutige
gesagt hat dann wäre das natürlich schon
ein symbolischer Sieg für Russland
allerdings auch einer den das Land mit
einem hohen Preis an Menschen Leben
bezahlt hat und viele Beobachter
schätzen den strategischen Wert der
Stadt auch als er nicht so hoch ein und
ähm genau das ist also sozusagen die
Situation jetzt dass ich ähm im Moment
auch nicht glaube beispielsweise dass
die die Kämpfe rund um Bach mutig jetzt
durch die Situation die da eingetreten
ist erstmal beruhigen werden auch weil
die ukraineische Seite in den
vergangenen Tagen für sich beansprucht
hat dass sie eben an den Rändern also an
den Flanken von bachmut-gelände Gewinne
gemacht hat danke schön Krüger
Tim Krüger ist im Moment in saporicia um
von dem Atomkraftwerk in der Region dort
zu berichten seit Beginn des Krieges ist
dieses größte Atomkraftwerk Europas von
russischen Truppen besetzt die sechs
Reaktoren sind zwar außer Betrieb
dennoch die Angst vor einem atomaren
Unfall ist groß nicht zuletzt weil die
Ukraine womöglich versucht das
Atomkraftwerk saporisia zurückzuerobern
früher haben sie direkt am Atomkraftwerk
saporicia gelebt und die meisten auch
gearbeitet nach und nach sind sie vor
den russischen Truppen geflüchtet die
die Nuklearanlage bis heute besetzt hat
mindestens einmal pro Woche werden
Hilfsgüter an Sie ausgegeben nun steht
die ukrainische gegen Offensive wohl
bevor und könnte auch das Gebiet der
Anlage betreffen
sie werden es so lange halten wie
möglich unser Militär wird sie nicht
bombardieren ich denke dass sie sie
einkesseln und vertreiben werden
schon kurz nach Beginn des Krieges wurde
rund um das Kernkraftwerk gekämpft die
Angst vor einem Unfall ist seither groß
auch wenn es von Russen besetzt ist wird
es noch immer von ukrainischen
Mitarbeitern betrieben
olexiek war Ingenieur dort der Kontakt
zu den Kollegen werde immer schwieriger
sagt er
die Zahl der Besatzer im Atomkraftwerk
wächst stetig das ist für die
Mitarbeiter ziemlich verstörend sie sind
sowieso moralisch in einer schwierigen
Lage
auch der Bürgermeister von Erna Huda
jener Satellitenstadt am Atomkraftwerk
ist geflohen er spricht von schweren
Misshandlungen der verbliebenen
ukrainischen Mitarbeiter
die Besatzer bringen Menschen mit
Position einer Meinung in Folter einige
kommen nicht Leben zurück einige sind
danach gesundheitlich geschädigt oder
psychisch gebrochen
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
hat die Anlage seit Kriegsbeginn besucht
hat Beobachter vor Ort und Bahn vor der
aktuellen Situation das Gelände sei fast
schon eine Militärbasis sagt die
ukrainische Betreiber Firma die
Besetzung des Atomkraftwerks ist die
größte Bedrohung der Zeit wenn
Radioaktivität freigesetzt wird dann
bedroht dass die ganze Welt das Gelände
ist offenbar völlig vermiet sollte es
befreit werden dann wird es viel Arbeit
kosten die Sicherheit im Atomkraftwerk
saporizia wieder herzustellen
Arbeitsminister Heil will mehr
Pflegekräfte aus dem Ausland anwerben
und zwar aus Ländern in denen es mehr
junge und gut ausgebildete Menschen gäbe
als der dortige Arbeitsmarkt aufnehmen
können sagte er der neuen Osnabrücker
Zeitung im Juni will er deshalb
gemeinsam mit Außenministerin baerbock
nach Brasilien reisen außerdem gebe es
Gespräche mit Indonesien und Mexiko in
Italien bleibt die Hochwasserlage
dramatisch die Zahl der Toten ist auf
mindestens 14 gestiegen es treten
weiterhin Flüsse über die Ufer besonders
gefährlich sind aktuell Erdrutsche zudem
wird neue Regen erwartet die betroffene
Region Emilia Romania liegt im Norden
Italiens in einigen Gebieten nahe der
Adriaküste gilt noch immer die höchste
Alarmstufe Alexandra Vacano berichtet
meine Romania du bist das da du bist die
Liebe sie singen die Hymne ihrer Region
zusammen und halten zusammen hier in
Cesena
und sagen Grazie danke an all die jungen
Freiwilligen die gekommen sind um zu
helfen
sie haben angefangen zu singen und
plötzlich hat jeder gesungen wenn wir
sie nicht hätten wären wir noch
verzweifelter
zwischendurch Trost dann geht es weiter
im Kampf gegen den Schlamm mit geballter
Kraft auch in Ravenna
vielerorts steht immer noch das Wasser
die große Sorge dass es mit neuem Regen
noch schlimmer werden könnte
immer noch müssen vom Wasser
eingeschlossene befreit werden
aber es gibt auch immer noch Menschen
die sich nicht retten lassen wollen und
versorgt werden müssen wie informieren
warum sind sie zu Hause geblieben fragt
er wegen meiner Katzen sagt sie
riskiert nicht euer Leben warnt der
Präsident der Region die Lage im
appellin ist immer noch kritisch es gibt
noch 300 aktive Erdrutsche 500 Straßen
sind unterbrochen oder zerstört jetzt
zeigen sich die Schäden sie sollen sich
auf einige Milliarden Euro belaufen so
die Behörden fast 100 Gemeinden sein
betroffen noch gibt es keine Entwarnung
es geht immer noch Alarmstufe Rot in der
Emilia Romania
griechenland steht vor einer
Richtungswahl die konservative Regierung
von Ministerpräsident mit zu Tages kann
Erfolge vorweisen hat Reformen
durchgesetzt und die Finanzen saniert
doch viele griecheninnen und Griechen
fühlen sich sozial abgehängt leiden
unter den Folgen des Sparkurses darauf
setzt die Links gerichtete Opposition um
den früheren Regierungschef Zebras über
Griechenland am Tag vor der Wahl Andreas
Postel
die Inszenierung vor der Akropolis zum
Wahlkampfabschluss bewusst gesetzt
Ministerpräsident Kiriakos möchte an das
Positive Griechenland Bild anknüpfen im
Laufe seiner Regierungszeit hat er das
Land stabilisieren können vom Sorgenkind
Europas ist längst nicht mehr die Rede
seit Wochen wird der Spitzenkandidat der
konservativen dafür seinen Reformkurs
vorzusetzen
das Land auf ein Geistes Aufschwung zu
bringen und ich denke die meisten
griechischen Bürger erkennen das an wir
haben die Arbeitslosigkeit gesenkt
Infrastrukturprojekte auf den Weg
gebracht und die Sicherheit des Landes
garantiert
doch der Aufschwung kommt längst nicht
bei allen an nach 10 Jahren hart im
Sparkurs in Folge der
Staatsschuldenkrise ist das
Verarmungsrisiko in Griechenland hoch
trotz staatlicher Hilfen
54 Euro habe ich dazu bekommen einmal im
Monat 54 Euro da muss ich trotzdem hier
nach dem aller billigsten suchen um es
kaufen zu können
die soziale Gerechtigkeit ist das große
Thema von Oppositionsführer Alexis
Zebras Wahlkampfabschluss der Linken
sirizer auf dem Syntax in Athen
Schluss mit der sozialen Ungerechtigkeit
Schluss mit Profitgier Schluss mit der
Ungleichheit
laut aktuellster Umfragen in Athen muss
Ministerpräsidenten mit so takes um
seine absolute Mehrheit fürchten aber er
ist recht sein Herausforderer wäre
demnach auf Koalitionspartner angewiesen
die sozialdemokratische Person könnte
zum Königsmacher werden aber auch
Neuwahlen sind jetzt schon im Gespräch
zweite Chance für Zebras oder weiter so
mit mir zu Tag ist am Sonntag haben die
Griechen die Wahl
nur knapp hat Amtsinhaber Erdogan den
Sieg in der ersten Runde der
Präsidentschaftswahl in der Türkei
verpasst nun geht es am 28 Mai gegen
Herausforderer Rollo in die Stichwahl
seit dem Morgen können in Deutschland
rund anderthalb Millionen türkische
Wahlberechtigte ihre Stimme abgeben die
hier in Hamburg im ersten Anlauf hatten
in Deutschland 65% für den amtierenden
Präsidenten Erdogan gestimmt
ohne sie und ihre Artgenossen wären wir
ziemlich aufgeschmissen ein Großteil
aller Kultur- und Nutzpflanzen können
sich nur mit der Hilfe von Bienen
vermehren gerade auch Wildbienen sind
als Bestäuber überlebenswichtig leider
nur finden Sie immer weniger Lebensraum
und Nahrung zum
weltbienentag heute zeigt mal Hugo wie
sogenannte
eda-initiativen gegensteuern
eine wirklich bunte Vielfalt rund 560
Wildbienenarten gibt es in Deutschland
auf Fleckchen wie hier in Bornheim in
der Pfalz haben sie noch alles was Sie
brauchen es ist eine sogenannte
eda-fläche also eine die sowieso da ist
und für nichts anderes gebraucht wird es
gibt sie inzwischen bundesweit
das sind zum Beispiel Flächen an
Verkehrswegen am Radweg das sind Dämme
das sind Böschungen das Entwickeln in
der gralandschaft all das sind die da
Flächen in diesem Sinn dort haben
Wildbienen Platz zum Brüten im Boden
oder in Totholz und es gibt die
richtigen Blüten insgesamt aber lassen
Pestizide und immer weniger Lebensraum
Bestände und viel falsch schwinden in
Deutschland gelten nur rund 37% der
Arten als ungefährdet mehr als die
Hälfte dagegen als gefährdet extrem
selten oder bereits ausgestorben 8% sind
auf der Vorfahren Liste dabei sind sie
wichtig Wildbienen sind ganz
hervorragende Bestäuber und viele
Wildbienen sind auch spezialisiert auf
ganz bestimmte Pflanzen zu deren
Überleben sie dann beitragen also
Wildbienen sind unverzichtbar für die
Natur aber auch für eine gute Ernte in
der Landwirtschaft und auch in unseren
Gärten die Hummel auch eine Wildbiene
etwa ist unterwegs wenn es der
Honigbiene längst zu kühl ist und
deshalb sucht die Ida Initiative weiter
nach Flächen die sowieso da sind um sie
zu leben zu räumen für Wildbienen zu
machen
ja jetzt zur Fußball-Bundesliga und den
ersten Entscheidungen am vorletzten
Spieltag hat ja genau seit knapp zwei
Stunden steht fest Hertha BSC steigt aus
der ersten Liga ab Enttäuschung in
Berlin nach dem Gegner Bochum zum
1:1-traf und damit den siebten Abstieg
der hertane in der Vereinsgeschichte
besiegelte thomas kulski am Stadion in
Berlin diese Abstieg kommt allerdings
nicht überraschend
nein das tut er nicht und dabei passt
dieser Bochumer Ausgleich heute auch
noch zur komplett vermale datensaison
der Hertha die vierte Minute der
Nachspielzeit der Moment als die
Hertha-Fans im Stadion und in den
feinkneipen in der Stadt schockiert
erstarben aber die härter ist ja nicht
heute abgestiegen die Hertha ist quasi 4
Jahre lang abgestiegen Stück für Stück
und das trotz einer Alimentierung in
Höhe von 375 Millionen Euro durch
Investor Windhorst der teuerste Abstieg
der Bundesliga-Geschichte eine Mischung
aus größten waren Traumtänzerei und
einer Geldverschwendung der extremsten
Art und jetzt jetzt muss die härter
sogar um die Lizenz für die zweite
Bundesliga Bank
Dankeschön nach Berlin Thomas golski ja
und hier nun die Ergebnisse vom 33
Spieltag Hertha Bochum wie gesehen eins
zu eins Bremen gegen Köln eins zu eins
Bremen hat den Klassenerhalt damit
geschafft Hoffenheim und Union 4 zu 2
Hoffenheim kann nicht mehr absteigen
Schalke Frankfurt 2:2 das Topspiel
Bayern Leipzig heute abend ausführlich
im Aktuellen Sportstudio und bereits
gestern Freiburg Wolfsburg 2:0 in der
Tabelle kämpfen die Bayern und Dortmund
um den Titel Leipzig heute Abend um den
sicheren Champions League Platz auf
denen auch noch Union und Freiburg
Chancen haben Leverkusen hat in Europa
liegt Platz mit Wolfsburg getauscht die
zweite Hälfte mit dem sicheren
Mittelfeld aus Köln Gladbach Bremen und
Hoffenheim sind dann müssen vor allem
Bochum Schalke und Stuttgart hertha ist
wie gehört abgestiegen
vorzeitig aufgestiegen liege eins ist
Darmstadt 98 nach einem 1:0 gegen den
ersten fC Magdeburg nach dem Schluß gab
es kein Halten mehr im Stadion am
Böllenfalltor vom Rasen war nicht allzu
viel mehr zu erkennen und die Party ging
bis heute morgen zuletzt werden die
Lilien von 2015 bis 2017 in der ersten
Liga
ja und die Fußballerinnen des FC Bayern
München sind noch nicht vorzeitig
deutsche Meisterinnen am vorletzten
Spieltag spielten sie nur 0:0 in
Leverkusen
Leverkusen den rot beginnt stark Maria
Luisa gross in bayerntour muss in der
Anfangsphase beim Schuss von Christin
Kögel den Rückstand verhindern später
kommen die Münchnerinnen der bei einem
siegfälligen Meister feiert ziemlich nah
klarer Bühl verzieht kurz vor Schluss
Lea Schüller köpft den Ball in der
Nachspielzeit an den Pfosten es bleibt
beim 0:0 die Münchnerinnen können
trotzdem vor dem letzten Spieltag
Meister werden wenn Verfolger Wolfsburg
am Sonntag nicht gewinnt
ja und zwei Spielerinnen des FC Bayern
nämlich Linda Dallmann und Clara Bühl
sind heute Abend zu Gast im Aktuellen
Sportstudio 23 Uhr geht es los und
morgen müssen Deutschlands
Eishockeyspieler bei der WM in Finnland
und Lettland wieder aufs Eis dann geht
es gegen Ungarn um den dritten Sieg
nacheinander gestern gewann das Team von
Bundestrainer Harald Kreis mühsam gegen
Österreich mit vier zu zwei dabei
überzeugte vor allem Stanley Cup Sieger
Nico Sturm der zweimal ins Netz traf ja
noch zwei Siege und Deutschland steht im
Viertelfinale danke schön wer einen Pool
besitzen muss mit überraschenden Gästen
rechnen das zeigte sich im englischen
da tauchte plötzlich eine Herde
Wasserbüffel im Garten auf und weil sie
nun mal Wasserbüffel sind testeten sie
auch gleich den Pool erst der Landwirt
dem die Meute entwischt war konnte sie
wieder einfangen ein teures Büffel
Vergnügen zum Glück hat die Versicherung
jetzt nach zehn Monaten zugesagt den
Schaden von 29.000 Euro zu übernehmen
morgen wird sommerlich mit viel Sonne
aber auch mit einzelnen Schauern und
Gewittern mehr dazu hat gleich Christa
auch wenn Christian Sievers freut sich
auf Sie um viertel 11 im heute journal
danke für Ihr Interesse ein schönes
Wochenende noch und bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend schön dass sie heute dabei
sind ja wir gehören morgen zu den
Spitzenreitern was die Temperaturen in
Europa betrifft mit um 25 Grad und auch
in Skandinavien herrscht richtiger
Frühsommer zur Zeit mit über 20 Grad bis
hinauf nach Lappland etwas gedämpfter
geht es aber eben im zentralen
Mittelmeer zur Zeit zu denn hier
herrscht der Tiefe Luftdruck der in der
Region weiter teils heftige Regenfälle
bringt in Kombination mit diesem
langgezogenen hoch bringt uns das
allerdings die milde Luft aus dem Osten
und das bedeutet auch heute Nacht ist
schon eine milde nach Temperaturen um 14
Grad vor allem in den Metropolregionen
wie rund um Berlin einstellig nur an der
Küste und an den Alpen und diese
sommerliche Luftmasse bringt auch die
Gewitter sehr so etwas in Schwung die
einzelnen Gewitter und Schauer von heute
Abend die verlagern sich in der Nacht
nordwestwärts dahinter klar ist oft auf
diese gewidrigen Schauer im Nordwesten
die gibt's auch morgen Vormittag noch
die bewegen sich in Richtung Nordsee
ansonsten startet der Tag mit viel Sonne
vor allem im und im Süden bei einem
spürbaren Ostwind nachmittags und abends
entwickeln sich dann wieder einzelne
Schauer und Gewitter auch mit Starkregen
in Richtung Nordwesten über dem
sächsischen und dem südwestlichen
Bergland für die meisten bleibt es aber
trocken und mit sonnenunterstützung
schaffen wir es dann auf teils 29 Grad
zwischen Main und Donau fast ebenso war
zwischen warm zwischen der Saale und der
Spree wenn doch ein paar Wolken am
Himmel sind auch dann ist es mild 24 bis
27 Grad sogar an den Küsten sind es um
20 Grad und genauso sommerlich bleibt es
auch am Montag aber die Schauer und
Gewitter Gefahren im deutlich zu dann
sind doch Unwetter mit Starkregen Haaren
und Sturmböen vor allem im Westen
möglich am Dienstag dreht der Wind und
aus Nordwesten wird es wieder kühler und
mit diesen Aussichten sage ich ihnen
tschüss